welcome to this video playing tashlan
last actors emo cozy more do I have an
info here no no name and playing the
calc on and probably we get the pawn off
on the exchange the pun off okay yeah I
play this somewhat strange line recently
have lost the game they I against
exactly this movie are played Bishop f5
but I afterwards found out that the
special g4 is the much better news still
I forgot how it exactly is continued but
this is what why why did he play the
five so quickly isn't 93 now a big
problem how would I see prevention 93
here Bishop d7 still 93 coming or not
yes sure check okay so let's see what so
what's best here can even think of it in
this check this is what I'm trying to
say something that should be at least
briefly considered or what about moon is
so I can take on f2 of course
yep come on let's do that it is not like
a why this in particularly were
coordinated here okay I can give the
check as mentioned i would also like to
play e6 of course hmm not not so sure
how to how to develop now he cannot take
on b7 now that that's clear maybe I
should just return him if he takes on b7
I've got rook be a droopy to which looks
disastrous my idea was actually now to
to drop the night to c5 where it is some
quite okay placed and yeah
yeah maybe just droop see a gem but some
I just need to move the Queen the Queen
c7 and that I can play your sick Santa's
queen is so terribly placed on before
really maybe even if 5v5 I can also take
on edge tool by by the way okay but it's
got Bishop e3 if i play e5 that's 93
actually threatened just start seeing
that with the winning the Queen yeah why
not actually okay 93 now wins the queen
is it it's there some trick I don't see
any jack this guy is playing instant
moves anyway check so Queen d7 now says
some sort of a check on the D file or
anything I don't don't see it if it goes
Bishop before I can maybe play Roxy for
even whoopsie form
yeah this is going to Bishop f5 or I've
got Queen 84 so i can i can just dumb
and castle yeah i think getting the king
out of the middle and let's take stock
what is this actually queen form two
pieces yeah okay i'm attacking g5 addy
for now maybe I could have done that
before even like reason I want Stewart
to castle first yeah I said don't get
those super quick play in the opening
and then you're busted like after nine
moves but ok let's have a look yeah d5 I
think loses the game already played like
in two seconds how much time did you
spend on that three seconds yeah and
it's easy to see that after Queenie for
95-93 you cannot prevent it and you're
busted so white must do something else
here queen bee three might might be a
move somehow getting out of the pin
attacking here I don't know this is just
very unconventional play hard to
evaluate after the game continuation
catches college so only a metaphor for
how to how to realize the advantage the
computer as usual is even more brutal it
wants to play b5 here yeah i briefly
considered that but well-nigh def to
keep it simple this seems to break out
the center even more this is what what
the computer wants to do with black
winning okay but this was probably not
bad whatever i did it should keep keep
keep an advantage big one yet here f
through 685 already wins
as it happens here it's also sang ya in
a bit of a strange game I don't
understand the super quick play as
mentioned quite a number of times on
this channel if you blunder like Eden
after it moves and you're lost 11 it
doesn't help you that you only have
spent 15 seconds I mean of course you
can play quickly in a position you know
in and out and let's say you play that
the slav exchange or whatever when you
have played this often enough you can
put out this moves quickly but this is
just a complicated position that he
probably has never seen before and the
d5 is certainly not the move that he has
prepared or anything ok whatever a quick
win thanks for watching